هل تندم على تلك الادعاءات
التي قدمتها بشأن الأدلة
التي قلتها عن روسيا وتواطؤ حملة ترامب ،
هل تأسف لأنني أعتقد أنها
أنقذت حياتي كيف يمكنني أن أندم عليها
لأنه إذا لم يكن الصحفيون يحسبون في ذلك
الوقت وتلك القصة؟  لا تأتي إلى
الصحف ، ربما سأموت الآن ،
لقد قلت إنني مستعد لإعطائك جميع
مقاطع الفيديو والصوتيات المفقودة من الألغاز
فيما يتعلق باتصالات
المشرعين المحترمين بقلعة ترامب مان
وبقية لماذا
قلت ذلك بعد ذلك  ما يقرب من عام واحد في
السجن بالنسبة لي يكفي حقًا أفهم أن
سؤالك يتعلق
بسؤال اختياري عن الاتصال
بأمريكا وشيء من هذا القبيل ولكن
لا يمكنني الإجابة ، يجب أن تفهمني
لأنني كنت في
حالة سيئة للغاية طوال ذلك العام.  لا أريد
المزيد وفي روسيا أحصل على نفس الشيء
ولا أريد أن أقارن ما هو
أفضل سجن أو سجن روسي ،
هل تم إخبارك أنه إذا التزمت الصمت
إذا لم تقل أي شيء آخر  حول تلك
اللقاءات حول أوليج ديريباسكا الذي قابله
بأنك ستكون حراً ، لقد تحدثت بعض الشيء
عندما كنت في السجن في السجن الروسي
وشرحوا لي بسرعة شديدة
الوضوح ماذا أفعل ماذا يجب أن
أقوله وماذا يجب أن أفعل '  أنا أقول
شيئًا كهذا الذي أوضح
لكم
العملاء الروس الروس ماذا قلت
لكم قالوا لي لا تلمسوا
السلة الكهربائية بعد الآن